determine whether the statement is
always sometimes or never true and
explain why so the statement is 3 X is
greater than or equal to X for all real
numbers X well let's try it out with a
couple of numbers if you try it out with
let's say X is equal to 0 if X is equal
to 0 then 3 X is equal to 0 which is
equal to which is equal to which is
equal to 0 which is equal to X so in
this situation if X is equal to 0 3 X is
indeed greater than or equal to X in
this case it is equal so we know that
it's definitely not never true now we
could try other situations if you put a
1 here 3 times 1 is 3 which is greater
than or equal to 1 so it is either
always or sometimes true now to figure
out to cross out always we just have to
think of a counter example and a good
counter example would be a negative
number if X is negative 1 if X is
negative 1 if X is equal to negative 1
then what happens then 3 X is equal to
negative 3 and X X well we already said
X is equal to negative 1 and in that
situation negative 3 is not greater than
or equal to negative 1 and negative 3 is
not greater than or equal to negative 1
it's less than negative 1 so this is a
counter example this is not true this is
not true in general it's not going to be
true for all negative numbers so it's
definitely not always it's only
sometimes true it's only true in the
case when you're dealing with
non-negative numbers so it's only
sometimes true